[Music]
so let's talk about data engineering
culture so one of the things I want you
to understand as you've went through and
as you've sat through some of these
things some of these talks is that their
data engineering culture is oftentimes
just implicit it's assumed they don't
really say hey my data engineer did this
for me they just said yes this is what
data engineers do and so when I talked
to new companies people who are
companies who are either just starting
out in their big data journey or
something like that they don't realize
that there's this implicit assumption of
data engineers doing all this so I've
kind of set out to say here's how we
create this data engineering culture so
that we start doing that and we start
working with that so what we're gonna do
is we're going to talk about what data
engineering cultures are I'll tell you a
few stories so you can kind of
understand it and under and understand
what's happening there and then we're
going to talk about how should you
create your own data gene engineering
culture and finally what are some common
reasons for failure this is actually
important because there's some reasons
why we actually want to talk about
failure with big data and that is
because 85% of Big Data projects fail
I'm gonna take a wild guess from looking
at your faces that you didn't know that
but here's the issue it has not talked
about quite frankly the the normal issue
when or the normal reason that people
when a Big Data project fails is they
say well the tech didn't work well
here's the thing the tech actually works
really well sometimes there there are no
limitations there are known issues with
the tech but when I talk to the teams
and I talked to the people they didn't
hit any of them but they yet they blame
the technology so what is the issue why
are these projects failing and that was
something I actually set out personally
this is my personal exotic exotic
adventure to go through and figure out
all right why are these teams failing so
often and let me tell you the opposite
side you sit south through this
conference and you've seen a lot of
people do
some really cool things and I completely
agree those 15 percent of projects that
actually get through this they do some
really really cool things they can
create some incredible value but there's
this whole issue of 85% of these
projects failing so that should really
give you some pause I can't remember if
gambling Fleagle here but where I'm from
gambling is legal
you have better odds of putting it all
on black
doing some blackjack put it doing rouler
wheel rolls and getting better ROI in
some cases so what I'm gonna try and do
in this and a pretty brief period is
share the things that you need to know
so that you don't fail so let's talk
about what that data engineering culture
is dating this is a culture where the
value and importance this is key value
and importance of data engineering is
recognized at all levels and this may be
something that that all levels us
another important part all levels means
that at the executive level all the way
down to the individual contributor level
if this is not recognized for example if
you have a a VP of engineering VP or C
XO something like that CTO who doesn't
recognize that value then they'll when
the axe comes or when they start to fire
people they'll say data engineering team
don't need it gone this is part of that
value the recognition of value so it has
to be an organization-wide
realization organization-wide of what
data science and data and big data they
require data engineering at some point
I'm going to create this visualization
have you ever heard of Atlas holding up
the world there's the or the sky
depending on which nephew read so Atlas
was there he was there holding up the
sky or the world and so what I think I
was data engineering is that Atlas
holding up the data science that is the
world most teams most executives are
focused on that world they're focused on
how do I get that data science how do I
get this output when the reality is they
should be focused on Atlas and saying
how do I get Atlas then he'll hold up
the world
where
get those data scientists those data
scientists will be able to do this one
of the manifestations of whether this is
correct or not is the right ratio of
data scientist to data engineers so one
wrong manifestation is basically zero or
a one-to-one ratio
that's usually an incorrect ratio
because that means that your data
scientists are doing way more data
engineering than they should be or if
it's a 1 to 0 ratio in other words there
is one data scientist and and zero data
engineers there's a big problem and
we'll talk about some of those problems
generally you want to be in the 2 to 5
ratio so for every data scientist you
would have 2 to 5 data engineers so
let's take a look at another
visualization of this this is what I
like to share with management and I
forgot to ask how many of you are
managers in this room out of curiosity
got it oh wow a decent number of you how
many of you our team leads in decent
number of you as well ok good so here is
a breakdown of where I see failures
happen so they're kind of going from
left to right you see team creation team
creation the vast majority of failure is
going to happen before that release so
there that first release there in the
middle that's when we've said hey this
team is probably done right and this
team is probably correctly assembled
correctly staff etc etc but up to that
point that means that the team the
management failed to create the right
team so I can't stress this enough early
production those 85% of teams failing of
projects failing that was specifically
due to management failures of not
getting the right team and we'll talk
about what the right team is in a second
but this is kind of one I shared to help
people understand it's only after you've
released your first code your second
release your third release your aunt
release then the management issues go
away and now you have a team that you
back off and you say ok I've created the
right team let me back off and let them
be successful
up to that point it is up to management
to make sure that they have the right
team and the right people so why would
you want to go through that effort of
creating a a date engineering culture
this is because teams may may not
actually fail they may simply vastly
underperform in fact some of the clients
I've worked with they were vastly
underperforming where in their minds
they were thinking hey we were doing
really cool things with data science the
reality was that they were like they
were writing their tryke as it were and
their their tricycle the three wheels
you know they were there on that little
trike they were going very slowly but
they were moving when they could have
been in that Ferrari but they were
limited they were limited by their
ability to create the data engineering
needed to create the data science so
what was happening at some of those
companies is they would get to this they
would hit the wall they would hit this
wall of this is a difficult data
engineering problem and they would just
stop and that's the issue that's what
we'll underperforming will mean is
they'll-they'll get to the difficult
part of data engineering and stop and
they can get somewhat there so
conferences if you is you've been to
conferences what they'll kind of say is
that they don't really talk about their
data engineering team they don't have
like credits at the end of their
conference talk saying and here's my
data engineer and here's a data
engineering manager they don't call it
off call it out but what sometimes the
leobens kind of mentioned it as an aside
and say I was helped out by the little
people in the data engineering community
so definitely something that we need to
have it's kind of an implicit it's kind
of assumed so let's talk about some some
brief stories here one of those is one
of my clients was actually hitting a an
issue where they were stopping so I went
through I interviewed a bunch of their
data scientists and started to ask
questions so what happens what happens
what happens tell me more about what
you're trying to do and one of those was
very interesting it was they they
thought that they were the business I
thought that they were really doing well
and they weren't talking to the data
scientists
when I talked to the data scientist they
said oh yeah we'd get this really cool
thing that we were trying to do but we
would hit this wall of what we couldn't
do we couldn't do the data engineering
anymore the system just became too
complex so here let's kind of unpack
that a little bit too complex for a data
scientist quite honestly most data
scientists are beginner programmers
don't take that personally most of you
are frankly beginner programmers so you
want to compare that with a data
engineer who should be a senior level
programmer maybe junior but mostly
senior level and engineer software
engineer this is down the line this is
exactly what they're doing this is what
they do on a daily basis it is well
within their ability to do those things
and that's what's really key and
important here data scientists are not
programmers they program they've learned
a program after a fashion they can
create these data engineering things
after a fashion they are not data
engineers
conversely you're not going to expect
the data engineer to create a machine
learning model this is they're two
different people and this is really key
or one of the big thrust of this talk I
want you to understand so when data
scientists do data engineering work
it isn't just here it it's gonna take me
longer it's going to take difficult
longer and what's worse they're going to
quit if you didn't know this already
they will quit if you're losing data
scientists right now you may want to go
back and look and see are they leaving
because they're tired of doing data
engineering work so kind of what we were
talking about that the personas that
what people are doing a data engineer
loves to do this sort of thing this is
what they've been doing throughout their
career if you start forcing data
scientists to do this they will quit
they will quit after one to six months
maybe a little bit different for Europe
but in the u.s. they actually talk and I
have these conversations with data
scientists they say I'm tired of doing
this I give it one or two more months
and I'm gone that this may be different
for your for Europe but this is exactly
what may be happening you just make
have a lead time so why why should you
do this it's because once you have your
data science and your data engineering
right you're going to really accelerate
things this is what I've helped my
clients do is now they don't really
think about can my data engineering do
this can I really do this
it's accelerated to the point where now
they're really working in unison and now
their data engineering team their data
infrastructure is no longer the
bottleneck what a bottleneck means is
often when whenever the data scientists
thought about doing something maybe
those of you are who are data scientists
in the room you're sitting there
thinking about I'd love to do X but then
you kind of stunt in your mind you're
thinking but that will be difficult and
that will be difficult and it's not the
it's not the machine learning it's not
the neural network that's making it
difficult that's thinking well how do I
even do that in SPARC and how do I get
that data right and how do I do this
that's what we as data engineers should
be removing this is the symbiotic
relationship between data scientists and
data engineers so how would we go about
creating this engineering data
engineering culture so data engineer you
may I'm not sure how many of you read
over ailee's data blog i write for my
blog or i also write a lot for a riley's
data blog and in there I create I've set
out to create definitions and these
definitions aren't to put people in
boxes it's much more to give a
definition for enterprises for larger
organizations to say here is what a data
engineer is here is what a data
scientist is so they can understand this
data scientist I'm not going to put them
in front of the keyboard to start
program so my 1 cent sentence definition
of a data engineer is that a data
engineer is someone who has specialized
your skills in creating software they're
a programmer around big data basically
they've focused in on big data for their
software skills data scientists they are
doing applied mathematics and then
there's another one
DBA so I kind of group a lot of titles
and that are there together and that use
sequels specifically into the term DBA
so those could be ETL developers though
could those can be sequel developers you
may have heard them be several different
titles I kind of group them all together
and there's an importance to this
because sometimes teams sometimes people
will think our managers will think that
the data warehousing team is your data
engineering team that is wrong there are
two very different skill sets and let's
unpack that a little bit AEDPA does not
know how to program they can only create
sequel that's important because you
cannot create in my opinion data
pipelines solely with sequel you know
count yourself lucky if you can I have
not hit very many people doing that it
is very very rare that people can do
that so you heard that they were talking
about flink on sequel yesterday and you
know that there's other ones the key
here is that a data engineer will be
able to switch between them they will
would know that something is better with
sequel versus something is better
written in code and they can choose
between the two if they only know sequel
they will use the worst tool for the job
when it's something else is better very
very important there so what sorts of
skills are needed this is just kind of a
laundry list I've written a book about
this that you'll see a link in a second
but you on every single data engineering
team there should be a person who
understands distributed systems a person
who understands programming an analysis
analysis this is not the level that a
data scientist needs this is analysis at
a perhaps doing counts very doing some
pretty rudimentary analysis usually it's
so they can keep it track of what's
happening keep some understanding of the
data their visual communication they
need to be able to visually communicate
what the data is saying they also need
verbal communication this one's
important because I need to work with
you as a data scientist so I see a lot
of data scientists in the room and what
what's going to happen is
the remember that symbiotic relationship
that I was talking about if the two
can't become symbiotic because they
can't communicate that's a problem so
your data engineering your data
scientists will need to have very good
verbal communication skills between the
two of them until you do that you will
have that disconnect and that disconnect
won't ever go away and you'll think why
it's because you don't have a good
verbal communication between them there
are a few other ones that are actually
kind of weird here a project veteran you
heard me say they talk about how data
scientists are new programmers well a
lot of people are new within data
engineering they don't have any purpose
if ik production experienced on getting
this these systems out
so what's corn and key and important
there is that then you need somebody on
your team to call out and say hey you
are going to hit a wall at this and hey
you are going to do this a year from now
only a veteran on your team can tell you
that though some of the worst designs
I've seen are from very new people to
big data and they will cause problems
don't and these problems aren't just
okay team look we're gonna have to spend
a week and pay down some technical debt
I've worked with teams where it's been a
year they have went eight created Doug's
such a hole for themselves that they had
to spend an entire year to get
themselves out of it so significantly
better to avoid that sort of issue
they're finally schema we're gonna talk
about this in a second you schema is
very very important you can't you need
to lay your data out correctly in a
schema evolutionary way we'll talk about
this in a bit of a second and we also
need domain knowledge some of your teeth
some of your companies it may not be as
important but if you're in something
like finance let's say it's very very
key and important to understand that
domain and until your data engineering
team understands the domain they won't
be able to create the data
infrastructure correctly so now let's
talk about some common reasons for
failure and I'll have to be go through
these relatively quick but one of the
biggest reasons for
for failure and I apologize if any of
you are either watching this or are a
DBA yourself or identify as the DBA but
if you have a team that is all DBAs than
you're calling yourself a data
engineering team you are unfortunately
and doing big data you're unfortunately
correct incorrect I should say the issue
there is that you more than likely will
fail with big data and I have the data
and experience to back this up now that
if you only have sequel behind you and
only a sequel ability you will fail in
your in your task of trying to do this
so a few things there's links there
there's minified links there one of
those is an ability gap the issue there
is that in in my work and research with
teams it is not simply a matter of time
or effort that a DBA needs to learn Big
Data and to create these data
engineering systems
it is a nyeon and possible sort of thing
it is an ability gap that it's not a
skills gap
so please do do think of that if the
data warehouse team is not the team that
is your Big Data team you need they need
to be software engineers another one is
that there's common one is that they're
set up for failure what happens there is
that the team will be the company will
be circling circling the drain what that
means is they're about to go under they
were out to go bankrupt and they'll say
hey I heard about that big data thing
it's gonna save the company that's I've
I've hit that before I've had them ones
where the the VP the cxo the CTO says Oh
big data that's just going to magically
going to make us more revenue well maybe
but having these unrealistic
expectations and desires sets a team up
for failure also unrealistic time frames
is incredibly terrible one thing to know
is that it takes up to and and possibly
even more than six months for a team to
just feel comfortable with big data this
is actually key and important if
you are embarking on a big data project
and you're saying we're gonna be hundred
percent of efficient proficient from day
one I'm sorry you're not going to be
I've taught way too many teams and you
may think but I'm smart I've taught a
lot of smart people this isn't a simply
an issue of being smart it is the sheer
complexity so in that that link up there
that complexity I wrote a post for
O'Reilly called on complexity and big
data in it I argue that big data is ten
times more complex than small data
please do understand this and
internalize that so next one is no one
understands schema so you remember how I
was talking about all the DBAs being all
DBAs being a recipe for failure
conversely having no DBAs or no one who
understands schema being another type of
failure and it's a failure you're not
going to hit from day one it's going to
be a failure you actually hit later on
in that cycle where the person who
understands schema on a team is usually
not the software engineers when I teach
and I work with a team I actually have a
very consistent question that I asked
them and generally it is a question that
is only answered by DBAs and the the
thing about that is that the DBAs have
spent their entire time and their entire
careers being the person who is there
about schema they know the schema they
know what things should be look like and
they know what how things should be
lated so in in a very clear sense it's
actually important to have somebody who
understands that schema on the team
because they are going to fight for
certain things that a software engineer
won't and for that matter a data
scientist load so it is actually a kind
of a weird thing you need in my opinion
at least one person who understands
schema now that may be a software
engineer may but in my experience it's
mostly a it's actually mostly a DBA
there so one thing I want to be clear on
is a data engineering team is actually
multidisciplinary it is not just a group
of people with the title of data
engineer it may be a group of people
with mostly of data engineers but also
may be a DBA or two and maybe some
front end or visualization developer so
veterans this is super important where
you need to have a veteran when I've
taught at a lot of companies and when I
come in sometimes those companies will
be trying to leverage a bunch of junior
engineers they couldn't find senior
people so what they'll get is a gaggle
or a bunch of junior engineers and
they'll put them all on that team now
the issue with junior engineers is the
naivete they are going to do something
stupid and something stupid in big data
doesn't mean it performs poorly it means
that it performs terribly and you're
going to have to spend months digging
yourselves out so I've been I've worked
with teams and one of the junior
engineers or mid-level engineers will
come up to me and say hey what do you
think it is a design and within 10
minutes I can save them a month it's
that it's that important it's the
designs can be that bad so it's very
very key and very very important you
need to get some kind of veteran skill
on your team
and finally and too ambitious how many
of you have a project where you're going
from zero to Big Data the issue there is
that you can't really do that I've
talked with teams where they say here's
my proposed architecture and what they
did is they took some conference talk of
somebody who said here's here's our
architecture and they said alright
everybody this is our architecture this
is what we're going to do the issue
there is that they're not telling you
some things from the stage like you
didn't raise your hand and say how many
iterations did it take you to get to
that architecture how many years did it
take you to get to - what you're showing
up on the screen conference talks did
not show that they don't talk about the
grueling thing that they took there and
so what will happen is middle managers
sometimes architects will take that and
say boom I could go from zero to this
they they did it right it is possible so
the the real key issue there for you as
you come
through and look at these talks is that
the architecture that they showed you
wasn't version 1 it's version 3 it's
version 5 depending on how old the
company is they have actually iterated
on that architecture several different
times so you can you can cut that but
you can't go from nothing to that this
is how I see teams really fail is that
the they say here's our architecture and
they make they go through the company
and they show it to everybody the VPS
and everybody buys in and then a month
later two months later six months later
the the VP calls and says hey I want a
demo in there they say I can't demo this
this is that the demo is another two
years outlook you signed off on the
Gantt chart he says no I want to see
what you're doing so what I when I work
with teams I recommend that they do this
in much more smaller smaller chunks that
I believe that there's a velocity to a
data engineering team I believe that a
team has to gain velocity and as they do
it in smaller chunks so you don't do all
here's an entire data platform all ready
to go it's piecing off and creating that
data platform kind of like what those
conference talks are telling you so very
very key so if this sounds like your
team you will need to take an honest
look at your team this is actually
important honest looks are are actually
really difficult to do this is something
I could do as an outsider I can look at
a team and say boom boom boom you need
to do this you need to do that
internally sometimes that's either
difficult a for because it may be that
your friends you've known them maybe
there's some other reasons some kind of
political reason a when I come in I'm
able to say hey you need to make these
changes and if you make these changes
will be so much better off you need to
check and make sure your skin your teams
don't have a skill gap or worse yet an
ability gap the issue with ability gaps
is usually ability gaps are not known
it's kind of they're lurking underneath
the covers but you do need to know and
you need to be watching and actually
dealing with these ability gaps
so this is the the link to my book I
wrote a book about data engineering
teams that's the minified URL to get
there it will help you it'll explain
some of these things that I talked about
in this talk about what should a data
engineering team look like how should
you actually go through how should the
data engineering team actually work with
a data science team these are the sorts
of things that you can do and it has to
be doing multidisciplinary do make sure
that you get help this is actually an
important thing and I think that if
there's a big difference between Europe
and us so I deal a lot with both I deal
with companies around the world what I
found is that in the u.s. you have to
showing any sort of needing of help
means that you're weak and that you
don't know what you're doing I found
that Europe is a bit more outreach that
they do realise their limits and that
they will ask for help so what I would
highly suggest is that if any of this
rings true if any of this does sound
sound like your team I would really
strongly recommend you get help early
the reason for that is because of the
ROI or the return on investment if you
do this wrong the wrong wrongness
doesn't cost you a week or two like it
does with small data doing this wrong
will cost you six months a year and when
you costly you when you have that sort
of cost sometimes that will cost people
their jobs and that's really something
you want I want people to avoid and
that's kind of why I set out personally
on this journey I set out on this
current a personal journey of educating
people on this because I saw these
failures and I'm tired of seeing
failures I am sharing with you all the
research I've done so that I really want
to see you avoid this please do avail
yourself of these things that I've
created so that you can avoid it yeah I
do I would love for every single one of
you to be in that 15% of successes let's
let's push up that number of successes
because that's pretty bad I know all of
us in this room
we we don't want to see a 85% of
failures because that means that our
industry isn't going to grow that those
companies are going to can or they're
going to fire that team or they're not
going to invest in this because they're
not seeing value and that's that's a key
issue that that I've been dealing with
personally so when should you fix these
problems if this sounds like your team
if this sounds like your heading if
you're a train heading toward that brick
wall the best time to that you know what
the cheapest time to figure out if
you're doing something wrong it's up on
a whiteboard before you've done that but
some of you may have already Dwight
boarded some of you may have already put
in months into the code you do need to
if you are if you are headed towards
that brick wall it's never too late fix
it just costs more and more the further
you go go down that track because then
you're going to have to really bring it
back you'll have to bring back even more
and fix even more there's even higher
technical debt there so with those happy
thoughts
let's open it up for questions
I know you have some questions I saw
some shaking heads okay go ahead yeah
he's got the mic right there all right
you got the microphone - oh poor fella
so at some point you mentioned that
there were some skills that Tim's need
could we consider having those skills in
different people or is there a subset of
skills that you know everyone should
have as an engineer that's a really good
question in my book I actually go
through what's called a gap analysis
those of you who are data scientists are
shaking head oh yeah gap analysis those
of us on the data engineering side we're
like gap analysis what's that
and it's basically his question no
single one person well we'll have all of
these skills so let me backtrack to that
slide just so that in case you you don't
remember that long list but no one
person will probably have all those
skills you've heard of unicorns and in
the Bay Area and Silicon Valley we call
them flying unicorns where they're even
more difficult to find and were to have
all those skills so to ant to the direct
answer to his question is all of these
have to appear in a team not necessarily
in a single individual and so what
you'll do and what I walk you through in
the book is how to do a skills gap
analysis of listening out your people
seeing what what skills are missing and
then certain skills are hey we can get
by on that or there may be other skills
where it's you know stop we need to stop
right now we need to find that skill two
of those on a data engineering team or
the top two there if you don't have
distributed systems and you don't have
programming that is the time to really
evaluate and stop that is a hard stop
end of story
I have the research on this other skills
there are going to hit you later on so
for example that lack of veteran that's
actually gonna really that's really
going to hit you not on that first
release it's actually going to hit you
on that second that third release
because now you're going to be iterating
on something that's already in
production and that veteran has to be
there to stop you from doing something
stupid answer your question very good a
very good question thank you I have a
question here yep and so I'm the CTO of
a start-up that recently moved
in a small data into big data and I'm
currently suffering the consequences of
not not having data engineers exactly as
you said I really like the speech I felt
really identified and my question is
about the the DBA and the schema because
I think it's kind of a blind spot
currently I in my team basically there
are engineers we already hired a couple
and they act as DBAs and so the people
that you've had so far are DBAs or not
know they're that engineers are acting
as DBA so far okay and my question is
could you expand on what exactly you
mean by a schema I mean I know what a
dark schema is but I don't know if I
exit understood what you mean by schema
and could you also talk about and they
work flow around that schema like who
should define the schema and who should
maintain it and what happens when it
changes etc so another good question
I just want to unpack one thing that he
said and then thank you for mentioning
that he was saying I'm moving from big
data the small data and I'm hitting
these issues that I talked about this
would have saved you a decent amount of
time I'm sure so good thank you for for
calling that out so let's talk about
schema so maybe you'd maybe you heard
the question I asked Wes and that
question I asked Wes about arrow was
about schema evolution and that is a
question that I would expect a person
who is who is handling the schema of the
schema part of your team that's the
question that they would be asking so as
you kind of self evaluate were you
asking that question or weren't you it's
not an issue it's not something bad
about you it just means do you have that
schema skill or not because you're
thinking about okay you've laid that
data down is that data going to be have
schema evolution and that's a really key
important thing so you then you heard
the back-and-forth with Wes and I where
he was saying this is all intermediate
data it's temporary data this isn't a
long-term storage of that and so that's
what that schema is that schema person
is they're thinking about I'm going to
lay down a petabyte of data
and I can't go back through and rewrite
that petabyte of data every single time
we make a schema change we need
something like Apache Avro to handle
that so there's the second part of your
question of how is the sort of schema
evolution handled this sort of schema
evolution is handled by oftentimes as a
business process so oftentimes it's that
one it's that person kind of being the
schema Nazi as it were they are there to
make sure that the developers software
engineers I am a software engineer we do
stupid stuff sometimes and they're there
to make sure that you don't do something
stupid with your schema that you don't
take a a floating point and make it into
an integer for example that's something
that the the schema in is seem evolution
can't handle or better yet they would
have actually prevented you from doing
that in the first place they would have
said okay this is what the sort of data
that you're going to be laying down I'm
not going to allow you to do that kind
of what your DBA is doing now you know
how you go to them now and you say I
want to make this schema change to this
table and they may fight you and they
may say no you should do that and
there's that back and forth that's kind
of the back and forth that you should be
getting at your at your start up or
frankly any company uh that kind of
negotiation that push back to say are
you using the right types are you doing
this for the right reasons are you doing
this this and this the other thing that
that schema person needs to know is the
actual bite level representation of this
and that's because as we create more and
more complicated data pipelines those
data pipelines aren't just gonna be a
bunch of files on disk they're actually
going to be real time they're going to
be here's the real-time representation
of this data and Kafka for example
moving moving moving real time and then
we go into our HDFS for long term
storage or we go into s3 for long term
storage we need to have that same schema
throughout and we need to do that
another common thing here is the unit
tests you'll want to make sure that you
have unit test coverage of the full
integration of your schema
so starting from the very first
supported version all the way to the
current version can we do scheme of
evolution backwards and forwards so
hopefully enough of something to give
you a good handle I saw another hand
over here somewhere it microphones
behind you it was about two key muscle
so okay good all right looks got a
question over here
Stage Left
hi so if you've covered a large portion
of like building pipelines I'm wondering
about running wear clothes and the role
of DevOps in all this is there do you
envision like a DevOps part of the of
the platform team to to help them run
their pipelines or is there like a
separate organization that takes care of
that bar can you say a bit about it
another really good question so kind of
to repeat his question is data
engineering DevOps and this is another
very common question in my opinion data
engineering is separate from your DevOps
team that actually goes to another
question I asked this morning where the
the person was asking talking about how
they were spinning up pipelines and I
asked them are you a DevOps team and it
was to to clarify some of the research
I'm doing there I just wrote another
post Pro Riley talking about this and so
my people that I want to put my software
engineer maintaining these production
systems because software engineers are
like a bull in a china shop they will
break things and and we're used to kind
of here I'm gonna play in my in my in my
database in my local database and I'm
just gonna blow it away and like no no
no stop because that's the production
database you know this is this is not
what a software engineer is or are
usually good at so yes I I would you
might call it data DevOps you might call
it data ops I think the one big
difference between data ops and DevOps
is an understanding of data so the
operations team needs to know about data
or excuse me they need to know about the
processes they need to know about the
issues and how to stand up a cluster
that sort of thing but the reason I
think data Ops you be separate is
because now there's issues of data so is
the problem due to a process failing it
problem due to a disc family or if the
problem due to bad data the data ops
team ideally will be able to identify
that because it's key that yeah
otherwise you're programming your data
engineering team will constantly be
getting paying for things that aren't
really a problem and it will just be
dragged their productivity down too much
so we need to have this data of team
that kind of says oh yes this is a data
issue let me handle this
and it's up when I'll Riley the data it
was a sponsored post but it's up there
now he's gone for round two yeah hi so
everybody's data-driven now so I'm here
yeah okay I see you everybody is data
driven out or we have data teams
everywhere doing everything and
sometimes the team is a bit of far from
main company business so and developers
feel bitter frustrated by what they are
doing why they're doing so what we
suggest to do in this case how to boost
up motivation or something like that so
let me restate your question you tell me
if this is the right question you're
kind of asking me should a data
engineering team be located with the
business unit or as a separate IT org is
that about your question yeah I mean we
applied data techniques in every site of
a company I don't know for everything
done so what my my depending on the size
of the company I would say that there
are there are a couple different routes
I've worked with teams on one is to have
a centralized data engineering team
that's more consultative I talked about
that my book where whenever a team wants
to deal with something data related
they'll come in and they'll say hey I
have this project and the data
engineering team will actually act kind
of like a consulting arm help them
create that there's another part to that
where that you're mentioning of the
team's being too too isolated to - all
over the place and the issue there is
then it becomes a hub-and-spoke model
where there's a data engineer or data
engineers located in the business unit
to understand that domain
and so we have that domain knowledge
maybe what you're seeing is a
manifestation of a lack of domain
knowledge or perhaps even interesting
domain let's just kind of put it out
there in sometimes these jobs sometimes
these jobs are boring of hey let me eat
yelled out for you I'd rather have
something more interesting that so
perhaps locating them within the
business unit where they're that they
then have a strong relationship back to
that hub of the data engineering team
that's another route that I've worked
with teams on if you want to follow up
with that I talked to me at the office
our time for one more or yeah one more
if I can ask it and the rest we can take
to office hours no we can't let you ask
that what do you think should ask go for
it be so with the proliferation of SAS
tools and hosted data infrastructure
right I think of something like Google
Cloud dataflow which sort of simplifies
a lot of things and abstract away a lot
of the previously necessary
infrastructure do you think that's
changing the the skills and the culture
that are needed inside certain teams
where they don't have to have such a
depth of data engineering experience do
you see a trend there I I don't see this
going down and that this is actually an
interesting question I'll answer it with
my general theory and then I'll talk a
little bit about it I don't believe that
a big data a general-purpose big data
system can be made simple or easy it can
be made easier but it cannot be made
simple I think that only specific use
cases and very specific industries can
be you can only have a specific purpose
built system for this thing that can be
easier but when you're dealing with the
levels of complex complexity I don't
think it's bringing it down I think it's
it made maybe just a little bit but it's
not enough crucible amount where we can
say hey I can hire Johnny off the street
front-end developer and let's get him up
on this big data stuff I guess the ideal
I'd like to see is an eventualities
where we don't differentiate between big
data and small data kind of what wes was
saying we have
we have pandas for small data and we
have this other thing for big data we
have pi spark I'd like to see that but I
don't think that the that the people
that the bar will be lowered so it put a
different way put a more of a business
way that's part of the reason why I
started my business specifically into
big data is because I'd I see the
barrier to entry being pretty high of
it's pretty difficult to get to this
level and when people try to get to that
level and aren't at that level it's very
very apparent and you see it all over
the place
you